I did collect hockey cards as a kid
yeah oh yeah we enjoyed hockey cards
we had tons probably thousands
of hockey cards when we were kids
uh never like avidly I just got the Tim Hortons
whenever you got a little donut or some Timbits
when you're younger I collected other kinds
of things but not really hockey cards but it
wasn't that big and sweet nothing I did but like
in in Europe it wasn't as popular to have hockey
cards but um I did have a few yeah when I was
really young I did but I I can't remember who
did I had I would use them to play hockey on
like a kitchen counter and ruin all of them
we had tons probably thousands of hockey cards
when we were kids I remember we would get a box
hockey cards Christmas and we'd open them up and
we try to trade them to each other and then me
Jack and Luke like they'd make a team I'd make
a team and we'd present it to my dad and he'd
pick who had the best team definitely I feel
like in elementary school that was kind of the
age where all my friends and stuff had hockey card
collections we'd take our take our books to school
that we had in trade cards and stuff like that I
did yeah I had the binders with all the team pages
so like Colorado would have all their
players gonna be Chicago or Columbus
so I think I still have them at home I'm sure
there's probably a lot of dads who can there
a lot of apply a lot of Red Wings I got some of
those signs some Jersey cards from back in the
day if I went back I probably have some pretty
cool cards in that collection I had a couple
cards I had a Tim Taylor card he's from Stratford
I had a dad suit card for a little bit I remember
sitting on my on my mirror oh wait a lot like we
had the Sydney Crosby rookie goals card pack that
was pretty cool got a Gordie Howe one I thought
that was really cool I don't know if it was an
original one or anything but I got that I think I
do have them uh back at my parents house somewhere
I remember some Pavel Beret car that I have that
I like if I've ever had the most popular Brewery
cards I was a huge fan of the Russian rocket grown
up by a lot of Pavel Burberry memorabilia I know
regular we had a few cars from miagara or Mike
Modano was there remember that then Joe sakic
those are the ones I remember from the
car twice I had a couple but I wouldn't
say collected them got more Pokemon cards
than I did hockey cards I don't know I liked
all of them which obviously the Charizard was
it's kind of weird though like Pokemon cards
kind of like come back uh Charizard my grandma
used to always we would trade her a Charizard
for like four packs of cards and obviously
we'd always do it and we'd always get like
nothing in the four packs and my grandma's
just hoarding Charizards I'll never forget
that as kids should get me and my brothers all
the time and would never give the Charizard back
[Music]